hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts interplay between
federal law and state law regarding
marijuana laws presented by Jeffrey
Mathura he is a founding shareholders of
Barrett and Mathura I am Marge Murray
laberd's and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labrys laggards is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
racial events and webinars before we go
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
those offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Jeffrey Mathura I will now turn the
presentation over to him good afternoon
everyone I appreciate the opportunity to
speak to you today about a topic that
that I certainly find fascinating and I
hope that some or hopefully all of you
will find fascinating as well I am an
attorney located in Arizona and so my
topic today is talk about laws that
govern marijuana and it wasn't that long
ago that just having this discussion
alone would be illegal to even talk
about different ways to use and produce
and test marijuana in any purpose and so
here we are in 2018 and we're able to
have the conversation about laws that
have developed and are developing right
in front of our faces every day the law
is developing
in this area regarding regulation of
marijuana across the country and frankly
we're seeing it across the world but
what I'm going to talk to you about
today and hopefully educate somewhat
today is this conflict that exists in
the United States and it's something
that certainly myself and other lawyers
who work in this area have to deal with
on a daily basis and the conflict is is
is is between the federal law issue and
and enforced by the federal government
and state laws we have many many many
states and we'll talk about the states
in a little bit but many states
developing laws every legislative
session across the country you see
different states coming up with
different laws so what we're going to
talk about today is how the federal law
and the state laws play together they
don't play very well together but we're
going to talk about how they play
together where the conflicts are where
there's no conflicts and perhaps where
where we think this this whole area of
the law is going and it touches every
aspect of this industry whether you're a
producer of marijuana a seller of
marijuana a user of marijuana a real
estate agent who is helping someone open
up a business a scientist who is testing
the product a doctor who might have a
patient that wants to use the product I
mean everything in between it truly does
touch every industry that we have in
society right now so understand the laws
and how it all works I think is an
important topic so that's why the title
of my presentation is the interplay
between the federal law and the state
laws regarding marijuana so we're going
to start of course I messed up my very
first slide but we're going to start
with giving an overview of the federal
perspective on marijuana and the state
perspective on marijuana starting make
sure we all start from the same point so
the federal perspective
is that marijuana is a controlled
substance under federal law what that
means it's ill it's illegal to possess
it to sell it to use it to produce it to
touch it period marijuana is always has
always been and still is today
considered controlled substance or
illegal under federal law again this law
prohibits the manufacturing sale and use
of marijuana in all 50 states at all
times that's the federal perspective the
state perspective of course a little bit
different 29 states including DC have
passed laws permit the medical use of
marijuana we're gonna talk about what
medical use me twenty nine states we
have more than a majority and this time
next year will be more and two three
four or five years from now it'll be
even more states it's important I think
more than a majority of the states who
have passed some type of laws permitting
the medical use of marijuana the scale
and we tipped the scale two years ago to
get more than twenty five it really was
a watershed moment from the lost
perspective because now the court system
and the judges and those other
individuals that that operate under the
law you can see pretty clearly that we
have a national mandate if you will
about which way the population is going
so we have 29 states including DC with
medical use laws we have nine states
including DC or excuse me in addition to
DC they have passed laws that permit the
recreational use of marijuana so
recreational use is a newer trend in the
law
it's trailing medical for perhaps
obvious reasons it's more palatable to
state legislators and to governor's to
sign laws into their respective states
that first address the medical use you
have children who are having seizures
every day that suddenly are not you have
debilitating conditions they're a little
bit better to live with you have someone
with chronic pain who can't get up in
the morning and walk but if they have a
doctor's note an appropriate medical
note and take medical marijuana suddenly
their lives are improved so that's why
the medical
usually are leading the charge and the
recreational laws fall a little bit
behind
what does recreational use mean
sometimes we hear referred to as adult
use the recreational use does not mean
anyone you have to be over 21 and we'll
talk more about this later
yet for you're over 21 you still have
certain restrictions on the use of that
marijuana the recreational does not mean
everyone at a very minimum it means
someone over the age of 21 so that's the
overview the two perspective that we're
going to talk about today again the
overarching issue of what I want to talk
about is how does a business or an
individual involved in in some manner of
the production sale or use of marijuana
what medical a recreational operate
under the conflicting federal
perspective as compared to the state
perspective so the first place we're
going to start and we dive into this
topic we're gonna start with we're gonna
start with the federal law we're gonna
start with the federal perspective if
you will and why the government has
perspective that it has and that brings
us to a federal law known as the
Controlled Substances Substances Act
it's a law that was passed by Congress
in 1970 signed into law by President
Nixon it's a very long statute it's
incredibly boring to read but what it
does is it it classifies regulated
substances substances five different
schedules literally if you look down the
page you would see sheets with drugs
listed on them it's enforced by the Drug
Enforcement Agency as well as the Food
and Drug Administration and they have a
list of schedules they call them and
there's five schedules schedule one
through schedule five schedule one being
the most severe in the eyes of the
government drugs the most severe drugs
and the hides of the government and then
it goes down in severity to get to
schedule five if you looked it up online
you could literally read the different
drivers that are listed on these
different schedules marijuana is
currently and has been since 1970 and
it's currently today listed on Schedule
one of the Controlled Substances Act
meaning Congress believes is the most
severe form of drug other drugs for
examples and comparisons listed on the
Schedule one page are arawa n-- LSD
ecstasy these are all very severe and
serious drugs and in the eyes of
Congress they compare marijuana to be
the same what does it take to be a
Schedule one drug
believe it or not Congress has set some
parameters to govern themselves to
determine what should be a Schedule one
drug versus a scheduled drug versus a
cetera so Congress has set forth some
qualifications to justify the inclusion
of any drug here's what Congress says a
Schedule one drug has to have a high
potential for abuse has to have no
currently acceptable medical treatment
for its use it has to have a lack of
accepted safety for its use
even under medical supervision so think
about that for a second well let's let's
start with the context of heroin perhaps
we can all agree that there's very high
potential for abuse heroin and probably
these people much smarter than myself
could maybe think of some acceptable
medical treatment for heroin I think we
could all generally agree that heroin
doesn't have an acceptable of medical
use and and and I think we could all
probably agree that individuals don't
safely use heroin certainly there's a
risk for the unsafe use of heroin
so heroin ecstasy LSD we could all have
a conversation where we could find some
common ground to justify that should be
a Schedule one drug but now take these
three parameters and pilot of marijuana
high potential for abuse well we see
across the country that individuals of
all different characteristics are using
marijuana and and and not abusing it
they're always exact always exceptions
to every rule but by and large we could
agree that individuals can use marijuana
without abuse certainly not
high potential for abuse secondly
currently no currently acceptable
medical treatment for use what we know
we know from time now and from the last
several years that there can be
acceptable medical use of marijuana and
it can work wonders in children and
adults with different conditions we know
that because we see it and and and it's
happening all across the country today
and a lack of accepted safety for use
even under medical supervision well
that's directly contrary to what is
happening across the country in states
that permit it for medical use today so
you take these three parameters or these
three qualifications if you will you try
to apply them to marijuana it doesn't
quite fit when you look at what's
actually happening across the country
now Congress doesn't care they don't
have to care but they certainly don't
care that these three characteristics
don't evenly and nicely apply to
marijuana marijuana has been a Schedule
one drug since 1970 and it still is
today so what does that really mean what
difference does it make if marijuana is
a schedule one drug versus some other
schedule under the law well it actually
means a lot licensed doctors are not
allowed to prescribe marijuana it's
contrary to their licensing and they
lose their license as a medical doctor
if they were to buy marijuana even in
those states where medical marijuana is
legal as a Schedule one drug
clinical study they're not going to
happen they're prohibited by law so you
don't have an influx of money and
resources and and researchers and
scientists who are willing and able to
do true clinical trials and studies on
the effects of different types of
marijuana and there has many different
strands and types of marijuana these
days that your mind can possibly imagine
but absolutely zero clinical studies on
the impacts and long-term effects and
benefits and strength etc
of those drugs as well as no clinical
studies there's there there's truly no
significant research on the safe use of
marijuana because again it's would be
the same as doing research on heroin and
that's not permitted under the law so by
being a Schedule one drug
the government has hindered very much
the development of the safe use and the
in their research and the study and and
and the science behind the use of
marijuana as I've said a few times now
marijuana remains a Schedule one drug
today every year since 1981 there's been
a bill introduced by someone in Congress
to remove marijuana from Schedule one
he's scheduled to move it down a notch
if you move it down just one notch it
opens up the ability for research
studies etc every year since 1981
there's been a bill introduced in every
single year that bill has not even made
it out of the legislative committee
which for those who aren't familiar with
how Congress works is essentially it
hasn't made it out of the starting gate
yet not even to the point where it can
be debated amended and certainly it's
never come up for a vote in Congress
it's not even now the starting gate yet
there's another way to try and get it
changed and that's for someone to
petition directly to the DEA to the Drug
Enforcement Agency to have it removed
the drug from Schedule one to some other
schedule every single petition that the
DEA has received since 1970 has been
rejected outright what's interesting is
that tobacco and alcohol are
specifically exempt from Congress from
the Controlled Substances Act why is
that the case well
tobacco and alcohol have more history
behind them in terms of use in the
United States tobacco and alcohol have a
lot more money behind them when it comes
to lobbying efforts and financial
pressure if you will that can be placed
upon members of Congress and they're
just frankly viewed differently in
today's society marijuana has not
certainly caught up at all but with the
views of tobacco and alcohol we are very
far away from the day when you can go to
your local corner store and buy
marijuana you can certainly go there
today and buy tobacco and alcohol some
would argue that tobacco has a high use
for misuse as as alcohol that that that
there can be harm brought to the person
unless under the supervision of a doctor
you can apply the same characteristics
the bet to to tobacco and alcohol that
you apply to marijuana but they're just
treated differently because it's more
money for history behind them and
there's no similar exemption for
marijuana and the words there's the
suggestion by Congress that they're
interested in such an exemption so when
it comes to marijuana and the federal
perspective it's very easy to understand
what that perspective is that
perspective is marijuana and every forum
is illegal 100% of the time in every
corner of every state of the United
States there's no exception period
perspective on marijuana I want to move
to the state perspective on marijuana
and despite everything I just spoke
about despite the complete and absolute
illegality of marijuana under federal
law we have states that have decided to
go against the grain and we know that
states have passed marijuana laws to
permit the production the sale and even
the use of marijuana but it's not an
absolute situation they've passed these
laws subject to certain regulated
circumstances there are two broad
categories of state laws there's of
course that we've talked about here
today medical marijuana laws
and then there are states that have
created recreational or adult use
marijuana now we're gonna look at a map
of the United States which is gonna help
explain where these states are located
and what kind of laws they have this is
a map which was put together by the
Business Insider it's up-to-date through
the last well through the legislative
sessions in 2018 in the various states
you'll see as the map tells us that the
green states have legalized recreational
and medical marijuana and the blue or
gray states have legalized medical
marijuana only no recreational use
again if you spoke about earlier we have
more medical marijuana States where it's
permitted than we do where recreational
use is permitted what's interesting to
see that you look at this map is
legalized recreational marijuana was
primarily on the west coast Colorado
California led the charge then
Washington Oregon jumped on board Nevada
recently started but primarily on the
west coast is where it's been except for
most recently when we now know that
Vermont Massachusetts and Maine have
passed laws to legalize the recreational
use of marijuana which means no longer
can be viewed by by Congress is just a
quote-unquote liberal West Coast type
mentality for for medical marijuana the
map shows that it's spread fairly evenly
across the United States if we look at
this map a year from now they're going
to be more more blue states on this map
I mean Utah is is is taking the steps
right now to to have a ballot initiative
to pass medical marijuana in other
states as well so the the theory is and
the prediction is that eventually most
perhaps not all but pretty close to
all states will have some form of law
that permits the use of marijuana
whether it's for medical or recreational
again it'll be interesting to see what
this map looks like a year or two years
from now I strongly suspect it'll be
have more color on it than it does even
right now I want to do a quick
comparison because although we have 29
states that have medical marijuana laws
plus DC not every state is different and
frankly there are 29 different versions
of laws because every state it's
different I just wanted to do a quick
comparison of two states to underscore
even within the state level the laws are
not the same so depending upon where you
are and what jurisdiction you're sitting
in and what your use of that or one it
might be whether it's studying it
testing it using it selling it etc the
laws are different I just chose two
states Arizona and Florida that have
medical marijuana laws Arizona you can
obtain a medical marijuana card if you
have a qualifying medical condition it's
a card like a driver's license issued by
the state of Arizona you have to have a
qualifying medical condition and that
that phrase means something different
for every state in Arizona if you have
cancer
that's a qualifying medical condition we
can get a card Florida is the same thing
on this issue
you never card that you carry with you
and your wallet and all or on your
person at all times when you have
marijuana on your possession you have to
have a qualifying condition as well so
in this respect medical marijuana laws
are the same but then you can start to
see the differences as we dig a little
bit deeper in Arizona you can purchase
with your medical marijuana card up to
two and a half ounces of marijuana every
14 days there's a system that the state
uses the track how much you purchase
because when you purchase it your card
and your card number gets put into the
state system therefore if you go to a
dispensary and you buy two and a half
ounces on Monday and then you go to
another dispensary on Tuesday to buy
another two and a half ounces a big red
flag will come up on
their screen and if they're following
the law they will not sell you any more
marijuana until you're 14 days has run
Florida just again by way of comparison
is quite different in Florida if you
have a qualifying card you can purchase
the amount reasonably presumed to be
necessary for your medical condition as
determined by a physician that could be
a great variance depending upon the
person someone with a back pain issue
might be treated differently than
someone with the terminal cancer for
example so how much are you allowed to
purchase in Florida and over what time
period it varies from person to person
now you'll see on the screen here that
it says under Florida law as determined
by a physician and I've already told you
that physicians can't prescribe medical
marijuana so how does that work well
again just by way of an example in
Florida you actually have doctors that
are identified as what they call
marijuana doctors for lack of a better
phrase and they're not they're not
doctors in the traditional sense seeing
patients for various sicknesses and
illnesses they've been authorized by the
state of Florida to help facilitate
their state mandated medical marijuana
program so these are just two examples
again every state is different
you could have 29 different examples on
the screen the point is is that when it
comes to medical marijuana not only is
it contrary to federal law but every
state law is also different the same is
true when it comes to those states that
permit the recreational use of marijuana
I've chosen two states at random Oregon
and Washington just for comparison sakes
Oregon you have to be 21 years or older
to legally purchase and use recreational
marijuana same thing for Washington and
that's fairly standard across all states
at that basic level you have to be 21
years in Oregon you can legally purchase
and possess one ounce of marijuana
flower
happens to be true in Washington but and
the differences start to appear a little
bit deeper into what you might buy with
a recreational card in Oregon you can
buy five milligrams of edibles in
Washington ten milligrams in Oregon you
can buy five grams of concentrates in
Washington you can buy seven grams of
concentrates y-7 no answer other than
that's the number the legislature
decided on probably a compromise between
five and ten but I don't know that to be
perfect but they came up with seven and
the point here is within the
recreational laws there are differences
in depending upon where you're located
what you're doing with the marijuana
doesn't have to be using it it could be
testing it it could be producing it
could be selling it the amount that
you're allowed to have on your
possession at any point in time varies
now there's no question that the
production the sale and the use of
medical and recreational marijuana is
booming across the United States and I
have this slide to underscore that this
is a big money business there is no
debate about that for example in 2017
alone medical marijuana sales topped 3.2
billion dollars across the United States
in the states that permit in the 29
states that permit medical marijuana
that's a big number
in 2017 alone in 2017 recreational
marijuana sales was four point five
billion dollars and that's only in nine
states plus Washington DC if you look at
the projections going from 2017 through
2025 assuming no more states passed laws
to legalize the medical or recreational
use of marijuana projections put it at a
hundred and thirty one point eight
billion dollars from today through the
end of 2025 the numbers are exponential
and the growth is exponential so while
you continue to have
federal law saying you can't touch use
test or frankly even look at marijuana
without committing a crime at the same
time you have that you have projections
of a hundred and thirty-one point eight
billion dollars of sales of marijuana
between now and 2025 so the conflict is
great there's no question about that
and now want to turn the conversation a
little bit to some of the laws that
apply across the board and I thought the
the best place to start was with the
highest court in the land the United
States Supreme Court because the United
States Supreme Court has commented at
least one time on this issue in the
conflict between federal law and all of
these state laws that are popping up
every year there was a case back in 2005
that went before the United States
Supreme Court it was called Gonzales
versus Wright but the case involved is
most simplistic level you had two
California residents who used
doctor-recommended marijuana pursuant to
California's medical marijuana laws and
their marijuana plans that they were
growing under California law it was
completely legal under California the
federal government through the DEA came
in and destroyed seized and destroyed
their plants and they said hey you can't
do that we're complying with California
state law what more can we do you can't
come in here government and tell us we
can't comply with our state law the case
worked its way through the court system
and many years later it found itself at
the front steps of the United States
Supreme Court
well Supreme Court concluded that two
residents in California you're wrong
supreme court concluded that the federal
government has the constitutional
authority to prohibit marijuana for all
purposes and that federal law
enforcement officials such as the DEA
the FBI etc can prosecute medical
marijuana patients even if they're
complying with their state pass and that
marijuana laws so what does that mean it
means that the Supreme Court reaffirmed
the government's authority as being the
highest law of the land when it comes to
marijuana and it does not have to agree
with or take a hands-off approach when
it comes to state marijuana laws now the
United States Supreme Court did not go
as far to say that state state marijuana
laws are unconstitutional it didn't go
that far but it very much reaffirmed the
government's right to come in in to
enforce its law even in states that have
their own marijuana laws now
that was 2005 and that's a pretty strong
affirmation of the government's position
as of 2005 since that time we've seen
some softening of the government's
position when it comes to medical and
recreational marijuana laws I want to
talk about some of those softening
positions now during President Obama's
administration we saw somewhat of a
change in the government's positioning
of perspective more states passed
medical marijuana laws at wylde
recreational laws public opinion
continued to tilt in favor of additional
laws permitting the medical and
recreational use of marijuana so you had
this groundswell of support and the
anticipation of change in the
government's position and then you had
President Obama come out himself on
January 18th of 2014 during one of his
many press conferences he made the
following statement he said that he
didn't think he doesn't think that
marijuana is more dangerous than alcohol
now that might seem like a off-the-cuff
comment it might seem flippant it might
not seem like such a big deal in the
grand scheme of things but that comment
coming from the president at the time
really was a monumental moment for the
marijuana industry because if you think
back to the Controlled Substances Act
that we talked about earlier
alcohol's exempt tobacco is exempt we
think about the qualifiers to have
marijuana as a schedule 1 drug that we
talked about one them is the danger from
the misuse of that drug and here you
have the president saying that he
doesn't think in his opinion that
marijuana is more dangerous than alcohol
it certainly opened the door for a
change in the government's perspective
we then had something called the Cole
memo and the Cole memo it's literally a
written memorandum drafted by someone
with last name of Cole James Cole who
worked for the Department of Justice he
was a United States Deputy Attorney
General under President Obama he worked
for the Department of Justice under
President Obama's administration
he wrote this memorandum which kiss the
Cole memo what he did in this memo and
this is critically important what he did
in this memo is that he set forth new
guidelines for federal prosecutors
across the country to follow when
dealing with the medical or recreational
use of marijuana it was it's it's you
can look it up online and read it it's a
memo that says we want you to change how
you prioritize using federal resources
to enforce federal law and states that
have medical or recreational marijuana
laws so it was a big shift in
perspective it shifted the government
priorities away from the strict
enforcement of federal marijuana
prohibition and shifted more towards a
hands-off approach at least with respect
to those states that have medical and
recreational laws so what was the impact
the practical impact of this memo well
the number of federal marijuana
prosecutions declined in those states
that have medical or recreational or
wanna laws those states continue to pass
additional laws as well as new states
came on board without the fear of
exposing producers sellers users to
federal process
q ssin and then marijuana businesses
within those states expanded their
production and sale of marijuana and
marijuana related products because they
believed they had some protection it's
not a law the Cole memo is not a law
it's not passed by Congress
sounds signed by the president but it is
direction and guidance to the federal
prosecutors throughout the country she
shifted their priorities perhaps away
from the strict enforcement of federal
marijuana laws and towards more of a
hands-on approach so people felt a
little bit more free to comply with the
state laws without the fear of arrest
and prosecution all right we had the
Cole memo we now have something called
the Rohrabacher Farr amendment this is
the next step in somewhat of a softening
of the government's approach towards the
enforcement of federal marijuana laws
this amendment which was introduced by
two representatives one with the last
name of rural Bakker along with the last
name of Farr was introduced in 2001 with
this amendment through Congress said was
that the Department of Justice would be
prohibited from spending money given to
it by Congress through the budget be
prohibited from spending money to
interfere with the implementation of
state medical marijuana laws again
what this amendment said was hey
Department of Justice we're gonna give
you a bunch of money through the budget
process in Congress to run your entire
operations and you can only imagine how
big of a number that is to run the
Department of Justice however this
amendment said you can't use a penny of
that money to interfere with the
implementation of state medical
marijuana laws introduced in 2001
finally became law in 2014 as part of
Congress's omnibus spending bill which
is a fancy way of saying the budget for
that
year President Obama was was president
during that year and he he signed the
omnibus bill and part of that bill was
this amendment it's the first time that
Congress passed a law and it was signed
by the president into law to give some
amount of protection to medical
marijuana users this is the actual text
of the 2014 amendment it says that none
of the funds made available in that act
to the Department of Justice may be used
with respect to the states of and then
it lists all of these states from
Alabama through Wisconsin it's not all
50 states but it's it's a good number of
states so the text says none of the
funds can be used with respect to that
these states to prevent them from
implementing their own state laws that
authorize the use distribution
possession or cultivation of medical
marijuana it's not a long amendment it's
not pages and pages of legalities it's
one paragraph but it's a very important
paragraph now it's a great Amendment for
those involved in any respect with
medical marijuana but it has its own
limitations it only applies to medical
marijuana does not apply at all to those
laws dealing with recreational marijuana
there is no limit on the Department of
Justice using all of its money if it
wanted to to prosecute anyone involved
with recreational marijuana whether it's
producers sellers users testers you know
anyone anyone at all the Department of
Justice is not restricted the other
issue with this amendment is that it
must be renewed every year it's only
effective as long as that budget bill is
effective and so every year and
sometimes multiple times a year if a
full budgets not passed and they have
temporary budgets every time the word
budget is coming through Congress this
amendment must be attached to it it's
therefore often used as a political tool
Congress members will use this as
frig to achieve something else that they
might want and the budget deal because
Congress members know that this
amendment is critically important to
this industry and it must be included
and approved every single bill that goes
through Congress when dealing with the
budget now that's came into law in 2014
and it's been part of every budget bill
since 2014 obviously we've had a change
in presidents since 2014 a change in the
administration and what I want to talk
about now is a change in perspective of
the government since Donald Trump became
president we have a new Attorney General
Jeff Sessions who took office and was
confirmed when Trump became president
well on January 4th 2018 he
affirmatively rescinded the Cole
memorandum that we talked about earlier
if you remember what the Cole memorandum
is it was guidance given by the
Department of Justice under President
Obama for federal prosecutors across the
country to shift their focus away from
enforcement in states that had passed
medical marijuana laws well on January
4th of 2018 Attorney General Jeff
Sessions rescinded that memo here's what
he said I don't like to read to to you
but what he said is that he believes
it's the mission of the Department of
Justice to enforce the laws of the
United States as the previous issuance
of guidance he's talking about the Cole
memo there the previous issuance of
guidance undermines the rule of law and
the ability of local state tribal and
federal law enforcement partners to
carry out this mission my mission means
in his belief the enforcement of federal
laws he said therefore today's memo mean
the memo that he issued rescinding the
Cole memo directs all US Attorney's to
use previously established
the territorial principles to deal with
criminal organizations tackle the
growing drug crisis and thwart violent
crime across the country if you think
about what this statement really means
you have the Attorney General the top
guy at the Department of Justice using
words like criminal organizations drug
crisis and violent crime in the context
of marijuana and and in the context of
medical marijuana so it's very much a
shift in the in the directed
ministration to another so as of january
4 2018 the Cole memo became ineffective
at least under the Trump administration
you have a new shift from from Attorney
General Jeff Sessions so what was the
real practical impact of what Jeff
Sessions did well now US Attorney's and
every state has one or more US
Attorney's they are the top federal
lawyer or prosecutor if you will for
governmental laws within each state so
Jeff Sessions said hey US Attorney's you
can use your discretion now however you
see fit determine whether the charge or
prosecute producers seller's users or
others who have on their possession
medical and recreational marijuana it
great gave great discretion to each US
Attorney to make their independent
decision whereas the Cole memo was a
direction to shift their priorities so
it was a different perspective now from
Jeff Sessions he was very clear that in
his opinion and from the government's
position state medical laws have no
barrier to federal prosecution his memo
did set forth some criteria that he
wanted the US Attorney's to consider
when exercising their discretion you
want them to consider financial
resources how much money do they have
with respect to their budget to go after
it
they're all marijuana laws how serious
is the crime that they're considering
a 14-year old child who has seizures
every day or just someone selling
thousands of pounds of marijuana a month
under state law and then what deterrent
effect would actually apply by
prosecuting that individual jeff
Sessions has asked his US attorneys to
consider these factors were making their
decisions but we've had a shift now from
from complete enforcement to the Cole
memo under President Obama to the
sessions memo under President Trump we
are flipping back and forth when it
comes to the exact perspective of
federal federal law with respect to
recreational and medical marijuana so
where are we now it's kind of a
million-dollar question where are we now
today we still have illegalities under
federal law marijuana remains illegal in
all respects we do not have any law from
Congress signed by the president saying
it's not illegal we don't have any
decision from the United States Supreme
Court saying it's not illegal it remains
illegal under federal law today and
offer specs but still as we've talked
about today we still have more and more
states coming online in passing their
laws to create these situations where an
individual can produce sell use medical
or recreational marijuana the amendment
we talked about recently was again
included in the spending bill signed by
President Trump in March of 2018 so that
bill excuse me that amendment continues
to be included in each spending bill so
despite jeff Sessions memo despite what
he has asked his US Attorney's to do you
still have this conflict because you
still have this amendment saying the
Department of Justice can't use any of
its money to
fear with the implementation of state
medical marijuana laws so how does that
amendment interplay with Jeff Sessions
memo it's not frankly clear you could
have a situation and I think this is the
most likely answer to my own question if
you have the Attorney General the
highest-ranking official at the
Department of Justice telling his US
Attorney's to use their discretion but
they can't actually use that discretion
to spend any money to interfere with
medical marijuana laws
again it's very conflicting but that's
the situation that the government has
created and it's very likely that this
shifting conflict will continue into the
future every presidential administration
can decide how to deal with this issue
and frankly if you go back and look just
at President Trump and his stated
beliefs on this issue before he was a
candidate he was in support of the
medical use of marijuana as a candidate
his position as stated on the record was
that it's a states rights issue states
should be able to decide whatever they
want to decide on this issue the
government should stay out of it and it
should be up to the states now as
president you have his Attorney General
saying no it's a criminal syndicate it's
it's it's it's a cartel it's you know
these these big words and rhetoric when
it comes to marijuana so it's very
possible that this issue could change
within a single administration as well
it only takes one signature from the
President to change this entire dynamic
public opinion remains strong for the
medical and recreational use if you look
at some of the polls that have been
conducted 94 percent of voters favor
medical marijuana laws in some respect
today that's a big number that's that's
that's a that's a number that will get
politicians attention and should 60% of
all voters favor laws regarding their
creational use of marijuana that's a big
number too not quite as big as 94 but
it's more than 50% which is so just
going by polling and public opinion
there's going to be some pressure on
members of Congress to deal with this
issue despite these polling numbers
marijuana remains a Schedule one drug
today as we talked about at any point in
time Congress has the ability to remove
marijuana from Schedule one or to give
it exemption with asthma tobacco and all
but that hasn't happened and there's no
indication that it's going to happen e
so what do we do what do we do with
these conflicting laws what can we do
whether and again it doesn't matter what
part of this process you might find
yourself whether you're a lawyer like
myself
[Music]
produces marijuana under state regulated
legal system whether you're someone that
purchases marijuana for yourself or for
others whether you're someone that uses
marijuana whether you're someone who is
involved in some other industry that
this hits such as you know real estate
technology science research it touches
all parts of this industry so what are
you supposed to do because the minute
you lay your hand on marijuana or the
minute we have a conversation about
marijuana we are violating federal law
this talk under federal law I should say
this talk violates federal law we're
talking about how to how to how to use
and how to how to weave your way through
these different laws so what do you do
what do you do well unfortunately
there's not a lot of good advice but the
best we have right now number one I
always recommend that individuals
understand the laws of the state in
which they reside or work we saw earlier
state laws are different and so any of
the state law is it's critical now based
upon Jeff Sessions memo I also recommend
in an individual or a business
understand the views of the US attorney
in that state where they reside or work
Jeff Sessions memo gives discretion to
these US attorneys so you could have 50
different opinions from US attorneys on
how they want to handle these issues so
understanding not only the state law but
the opinion and views of the US attorney
is important to know what you can and
can't do with respect to however you're
involved in this industry I always
recommend that individuals contact their
local and federal level representatives
and Sanders those are the people are
actually making the law that will impact
this industry recognize that sustained
prohibition has never worked in the long
history of this country we see public
opinion where it is we see a majority of
states now having at least medical
marijuana law criminal use of marijuana
you can project forward over the next
five and ten years thinking perhaps you
have more than 25 states permitting the
recreational use of marijuana so
prohibition is not a an issue that is
sustainable long term in the United
States it just hasn't worked didn't work
tobacco didn't work with alcohol it does
not appear to be working with marijuana
right now as well and the last final
issue here is and this is what's
fascinating to me on this topic is that
history on this topic is being made
right now next generation to generations
three generations down the road people
at that point in time will look back
where we are right now and say that's
where these laws were created that's
where this issue really came to fruition
if you talk to generations above you to
be able to say hey in some states you
can go down to a store and leave with
marijuana in your pocket and it's legal
that concept is foreign to you know it
took to my grandparents for example so
when you think back or when you think
ahead to the future generations they're
gonna look back too
now and realize this is where this issue
was discussed in open forum where laws
were made where the conflict existed but
out of conflict eventually comes some
type of resolution whether it's this
year next year five years ten years down
the road at some point in time I believe
there will be resolution on this issue
to resolve this conflict that we've
talked about today and then history will
be made until we get there of course we
have conflict and we live in a world of
conflict when it comes to this to this
industry but you have to go through the
conflict to get the resolution and it's
very fascinating to me to be involved in
this process and this time of our
history to see how this all develops so
that's my talk for the day I hope it's
been moderately helpful and hopefully
somewhat interesting as well and at this
point I'm I guess we would go to
questions Thank You Jeffery mature after
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do thrown out best
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of you questions we have time
for let's get started our first question
is how has the Trump administration
change the way that government these
days marijuana laws well that's a good
question
every administration has treated has has
handled marijuana laws differently when
it comes to the states and what we've
seen with the Trump administration so
far is frankly some back and forth or
flip-flopping as they used to say right
now with respect to the Trump
administration is taking a very hard
line stance against state state
marijuana laws it is it would not be
surprising to see the Trump
administration try to get rid of the
Rohrback or Farr amendment that we've
talked about during this presentation to
put pressure on members of
Congress to to to not include that that
amendment given the position right now
of Attorney General of Jeff Sessions as
long as he is Attorney General it's
anticipated that the federal crackdown
if you will or the the the conflict
between federal law and state marijuana
laws will continue to become greater and
greater it could all change every
administration is different it takes one
signature from the President to change
things but the anticipation right now is
that is that federal enforcement will
continue to increase under the trump
administration thank you for that an
answer our next question is what
unintended consequences have occurred
and due to the government's decision to
Mateen marijuana as a special Indra
particularly with respect to banking
this is one of the banking's one of the
most important unintended consequences
of having marijuana be a Schedule one
drug under the Controlled Substances Act
because it's a Schedule one drug
banks are prohibited by law from taking
any money derived from marijuana in any
respect whether that's money from the
production from the sale from the
testing rent from a landlord for
attendant who runs a marijuana business
any money derived in any respect from
marijuana banks are prohibited from
taking what that means is that those
businesses operating legally under state
laws in the marijuana industry cannot go
to a bank and open a bank account and
deposit money into it and so it's
created a cash based system largely a
cash based system which pets own
problems inherent in it you have sellers
of marijuana under state laws who have
to put their money in a safe as opposed
to a secure bank account
so what you really you can't transfer
money from one account to another you
can't transfer it across state lines the
inability to use the banking system in
this country has severely restricted how
to handle the money that's generated and
we saw slides earlier talking about the
billions of dollars in sales last year
alone and there's no place to put that
money so one of the most important
unintended consequences is banking if
marijuana removed a schedule - or lower
then suddenly you'd have a mad dash to
the local bank to open bank accounts as
a place is securely deposit money
derived from this industry thank you for
that answer
it looks like we have time for one more
question our last question is what is
the future of marijuana laws on the
federal and state level my belief based
upon what's happened to her last 10 15
20 years I think what you're going to
see in the next 15 20 30 years is that
this conflict that we've talked about
today is going to go away either by a
decision from the United States Supreme
Court or by a decision by a president or
a decision by a sitting Congress all
three of those bodies the executive the
legislative and and in the judicial
branch of our government they all have
the ability to get rid of this conflict
and I think that's where this ultimately
is headed you will ultimately see a
system where some form of marijuana use
either on a medical side or recreational
side is legal across all 50 states
restricted but legal it will then be
taxed
they'll be regulated it'll be tested
similar to alcohol similar to tobacco
but I think that's the future of where
this is headed which is a uniform set of
laws that govern all 50 states in this
industry
I would like to once again thank that
free material for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know the today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you will receive an
email from Lauer that's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please shovel announcements of
your college who may have missed it is
like that that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye